So, summarizing, we have two
equations: a prediction equation, and
a correction equation.
Our prediction basically
takes two components.
The, the estimate of our previous step.
That is, our belief about X
after time t minus 1 was done.
And then, we have a dynamics model.
RIght?
And the way of thinking about this is,
the likelihood,
the probability that X could
be at some specific point.
Well, it's the sum or
the integral of getting to
that point from any point that
it might have been before.
Integrated over the likelihood that
you were at those points before.
This is a lot easier to see when we do
the particle filtering where we make
things discreet.
But for the probabilistically inclined
for you if you look at that and
you realize remember we
talked about marginalizing.
What we're doing is we're saying all of
the possible places we might have been
before, what is the likelihood of
me getting to some particular spot.
And we have to weight that by all of
the probabilities of having been at that
point before.
That's the likelihood of
being at that next spot.
And then you go to the next spot,
and the next spot.
That's the probability.
That's your prior belief,your,
of your prediction about
the places you might end up.
P of Xt given the measurements
up until now.
We don't have the measurement yet.
Once we get a measurement,
we can do a correction, right?
And our correction, we use,
doing Bayes' rule, right?
We have the predicted value from before.
That's the, the quantity we
just talked about producing.
And then we have an observation model.
This observation model says, well.
if you really were at
some particular point
what's the likelihood of getting the
measurement you just saw and by using
Bayes rule we are allowed we use that
to turn that into a prediction of Xt
given everything we saw including that's
why is in red the new measurement and
then like I said on the bottom
here it's just the normalization